all right Sean
Sean uh so you have an interesting
career you you work as a
what do you call I'm a sexual assault
nurse examiner sometimes referred to as
a forensic nurse examiner and this is in
Northeast
Indiana yes and uh
so you're working with people who have
been
assaulted yes probably all ages right
yes we provide the medical forensic exam
for individuals that have been sexually
assaulted
my youngest patient was 35 days old so
about this big my oldest patient was 94
years old
so we do the entire life span as well as
go to the morgue for a deceased
individual if there is a suspicion that
sexual assault occurred wow
so you must see all kinds of stuff
indeed I do
is it does it affect you emotionally
I mean personally you're you're yeah
you're weird if it didn't yeah it's you
were telling me earlier you like to
carry a gun with you everywhere you go
yeah for protection uh yes I do
um
yeah it affects me it affects the people
that care about me it affects everyone
it's a stressful job I mean what you do
you're you're hearing things all day
long
um I hear them see them collect evidence
and it's it's hard
vicarious trauma is real
and I feel like I'm pretty mentally
tough but there's times that um
we all just don't do so good especially
when we go to the morgue especially when
it's a kiddo yeah
what got you into this field
well ironically I had never even heard
of forensic nursing and I had worked as
a lactation educator for like seven
years for the WIC program so I was all
about women's health I wanted to work in
like labor and delivery when I got
nursing school that's where I thought I
would start and retire there
and so I got a job when I was in school
third shift I went to school during the
day and then worked third shift at the
hospital and I was in the nursery
because I was little man on the totem
pole so I took care of the babies in the
nursery
and
um I actually really enjoyed that a lot
and I knew I could bring the
breastfeeding part of it into it
to be able to help moms you know right
after they've had the baby and stuff
like that so it was going to be a good
way for me to get my foot in the door
and a couple months after I started
there I had one of the charge nurses
come in and she said Sean we had a fetal
demise and I'm gonna need you to like
take care of that and I'm like
I knew what fetal meant and I do knew
what demise meant and I was like
wait a minute I'd never got that memo
that was not part of my job description
at all that I can recall
and I just kind of stared at her and
she's like I've got two other moms in
labor I've got to go attend to them I
need you to clean this baby up
try to find some clothes that fit them
and get like the Keepsake photos
for the parents if they did you know
decide they would want those later
and I kind of was just looking at her
like waiting for some guidance and she's
like I've got to go she's like you'll be
fine Sean it's over there in the corner
and I'd been in this nursery for like
two months I never knew what this little
room was off to the left
so I just kind of she left there was
nothing like hey it's your first time
I'll like walk you through it it was
just like
and I went into that room
and it was like very dimly lit and there
was like a little table
with like this little Mound on the table
with the receiving blanket over it and
there was a very distinct smell in there
which was the first thing I noticed
and I was like well I'm cleaning this
baby up so I like got a basin of warm
water and brought it in and a washcloth
I put some gloves on and I
pulled back this little receiving
blanket
and
um
it it
did not look like a baby to me and it
was
baby was very tiny
and all I know is I had to do what I had
to do so I was told what to do so I
started doing it so I started cleaning
the baby off and
um
I just remember vividly this the smell
again was horrendous but it was like the
skin was starting to kind of Slough off
of the baby and I was like well
what I'm going to take it down to the
muscle like I was like this this is like
not something I can do and I don't even
really remember the rest of doing that
other than
I did it I got it done I did it I got
off work I went home I drove back home
got my kids off to school and had to
leave and drive 45 minutes up to where I
went to school
and I went to my classes I acted normal
I guess and on my way home as soon as I
got in the car
it was like the floodgates opened up and
I was just like what the heck I hadn't
even had time to process it at that
point and I was just like I can't
believe I had to do that and then I felt
selfish that I felt like that because
I'm like
I'm worried about what I had to do when
there's parents that just lost their
baby and it was just it was like a lot
of weird emotions that I had not had
about anything remotely like that
um up to that point
and
um
I'm like this can't happen very much
surely if I stay in this department I am
not going to have to worry about doing
that hopefully ever again
well that was not the case so that
happened a few more times I know this is
a long way about getting to the question
you asked
but it's the the irony lies and when I
left that job so I had to do that I
think at least four or five more times
with the fetal demise
and I finally just one night I was like
I just can't I can't do this I mean I'm
tough but my psyche I was in nursing
school I was under a lot of stress I was
like I can't do this
so
um my boss worked days so when she got
there I kind of
gotta got you know her attention and I
went to her office and I said
everyone here knows I'm not a wuss
because I'm very tough and I don't ever
want to appear weak you know and not
that there's anything wrong with that
but
um and I said to her I don't I can't do
this like more power to the people that
can I have a lot of um you know
I don't even know the word I'll give
them a lot of credit for the people that
can do that but I can't I cannot
hold and move
dead babies
and take photos of them I just I can't
well ironically at this point in my life
that is one of the things that I have to
do
in a much different location
under much different circumstances and
now when I look back those were horrible
circumstances obviously that's supposed
to be the happy place in the hospital
not where people are going home
empty-handed
um but what I do now is when I go to the
morgue and it's a little child and
little babies
um I am touching them and moving them
and collecting evidence and taking
photos so never would have I imagined at
that point when I absolutely thought I
can't do this I would be doing it and
under
what I have to share
Works worse circumstances because
not all of the kids that we see at the
morgue have died at the hands of their
abuser but
some of them definitely have
and that involves
um
things where I'm seeing vaginal injury
anal injury
ruptured spleen subdural hematomas
bleeding from head to toe or excuse me
bruising from head to toe and uh the
tiniest body bags you've ever seen which
is very disconcerting obviously
so
um that's only one part of my job most
of the patients I see are alive
and going through a lot themselves
obviously by the time they get to me
and we provide that medical forensic
component
um but we also you know offer
medications for sexually transmitted
infections we provide them with
referrals for
Counseling Services
follow-up to get more testing HIV
prophylaxis all that kind of stuff that
we don't have available in-house
so
um
I I will say this and you know some
people might disagree but more important
than anything that I can do
as far as evidence collection all of
those things
it
the way that I treat people when they
come
is by far what I do that's the most
important thing
um no one's coming to us for a good
reason ever
and anyone that walks through the door
has
suffered something horrible sometimes
they can't remember because of drugs and
alcohol being involved
but they have and your body keeps score
and I
I know that the way I treat people has
an impact and it can improve the outcome
for them by being treated with respect
and dignity right after something like
that happens
um I still don't think I answered your
original question of how I got into it
okay that's okay so when I was in
nursing school after that whole
the field of my stuff
I was in a forensics class and I'd taken
a few forensics classes some psych
classes stuff like that and we had a
speaker come in
and she actually works where I work now
and she came to talk to us about
forensic nursing and I'm like
this job is this I could totally do this
job I'm very methodical and
detail-oriented and I had never heard of
forensic nursing I'd heard of rape kids
because a lot of people hear that
terminology I don't think I've ever said
that
um
unless I'm saying you may know it as or
you know referred to as a rape kid you
see it on TV you hear about it that way
and really that is what we collect we
have a box and you know evidence is put
into the box sometimes we have to bag
other evidence up
but she came and talked to us about that
and I listened and I'm like hmm I think
I could do that so I waited outside of
the classroom and when she came out I
said
uh hey I really think forensic nursing
is something I would be interested in
and she was like little did I know at
that time how much people tell us that
because now that I've been there for a
long time you hear it I just heard it at
the pool yesterday and you know oh what
a cool job I would love that job and I'm
like yeah right you have no idea you
want to be on call all the time have no
real personal life and carry everyone's
baggage along with you and I just kind
of smile which is what was my my
co-worker did that day so she said well
after you graduate like hit us up and
maybe we'll have something for you and
she was being genuine but I could tell
it's kind of like yeah right
so
um it was only like a week or two later
I was on our University website which I
never get on I don't know why I was on
there I have no idea other than maybe
that was just I was supposed to be on
there so
um it said pediatric assistant and it
had listed the same place where the lady
came just to speak to us
and I was like huh it had no job
description anything like that so I went
ahead and
made a phone call they had me come in
for an interview and then they hired me
and it was very interesting I was an
assistant so I didn't do anything
besides you know it was pediatric
assistant so it was all the child
population so it was 14 and under back
then
so that was my first taste of
listening to Little Children tell us how
they had been abused some of them
thought it was normal
because that's all they knew some kids
know they will tell you they will talk
about smells they will talk about how
things made them feel
um
and that was like that wasn't that that
was difficult it wasn't easy and again
I'm like what am I why do I get into
this kind of like job like what the heck
and
but I knew that I could have a huge
impact there and I saw the nurses and
what an impact they had on the patients
and so I continued and I will say to
hire people in school as a pediatric
assistant was a good very uh smart of
them because it would be the perfect
weed out process because if you couldn't
hack it doing that
before you are able to actually collect
evidence and do all that you're not
gonna you're not gonna make it there so
I did make it there
um and then I went on to get my
um finish my degree and then I went
through all the training to become a
sexual assault nurse examiner and then
the preceptorship so you initially you
have like a education portion and then
your preceptorship is where you follow
the experiencing
so I did that for the adult adolescent
population and then I did that for the
Pediatric population so all in all that
takes about a year and a half
and I was doing other jobs while I was
doing that so I was doing some hospice
some Long-Term Care Pediatric nurse I
was busy working like every weekend and
a lot I was working a lot knowing that
at some point I would only work where
I'm working now
um
again the deeper you get into it the
more difficult it becomes because it's
just more baggage more baggage every day
in some cases hits you harder than
others and
I will say this
um
one of your interviews with Eve from
Connecticut
she talked about afterwards and her her
stuff was so horrendous I can't even
imagine but she talked about how 99 of
the cops were really good because we
work with law enforcement DCS all these
people and get to know them because we
work around them so often and when she
said that how that one cop acted with
her in the car it ticked me off then she
went on to say how crappy the nurse was
that collected her evidence
and that irritated me it's no end and
I will say this forensic nurses are a
different breed and they're very
passionate about what they do
and if I had to guess
she was probably an ER nurse that it was
already taken care of two or three
patients I'm not justifying her behavior
because I know
we all have baggage but when you start
taking care of your patients you have to
be there for them you can't bring your
baggage into a lot of jobs but nursing
especially
and how harmful that was to her and how
much that hurt her by treating being
treated the way she was by that nurse
because I think she was kind of like
here I just get down shift and this is
the first thing I have to do I'm
thinking man I gotta get up in the
middle of the night all the time to come
do these cases and I would never think
of complaining to
a victim of sexual assault well so I
feel like this needs to be some
Redemption for sexual assault nurse
examiners again I think it was probably
an ER nurse that was really busy and
this was thrown on her yeah and because
a lot of times they're asking people to
do it that aren't trained to do it or
they've only done a couple in some
states you open this box up and it's got
like instructions that could take you an
hour to read I've never read the
instructions in there we don't need to
that's part of what we learn
in forensic nursing because those
instructions mean nothing when it's
based on
the disclosures that are made or not
made because you know if I have a kid in
the morgue that's deceased can he tell
me what happened or can she tell me what
happened no so I have to go based on
I don't know what happened so I am going
to
do absolutely as many swabs and collect
as much evidence as I can and you're
asking questions
if when they're alive yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's almost like what you do is
a hybrid of law enforcement and nursing
well there there's a distinct difference
only because I'm the medical component
and they are part of all the
investigatory stuff so every question I
ask really and we have to make that
um differentiation because of testifying
and stuff like that because we don't
work for law enforcement we don't work
for Department of Child Services all of
my documentation becomes part of their
investigation
so the questions that I ask I'm really
asking them more for
it it guides the forensic exam so if
they can't remember something again or
they don't know then I am collecting
virtually everything I can if they can
specify things that happen I don't want
to have to would I want to have to do
anything below the waist on somebody
that's already been traumatized that
nothing happened on there and that's
what some states
will have nurses do we don't need to do
we can do a head to toe exam but there's
no reason for me to collect evidence
from a female sex organ when everything
happened orally or something like that
because especially for a child what
they're not going to understand why
you're doing any of that
so yeah the the
exam itself is totally Guided by that so
are the medications that we offer all
that type of thing
and I will say I I treat my patients
with such compassion but I'm very I'm a
straight shooter I'm super easy to get
along with
um
and they feel comfortable because I
luckily I'm very blessed that I can
build rapport with people pretty quickly
or it would make my job very difficult I
think
um but they will I almost always make
people laugh while they're there at some
point because I'm very sarcastic too and
I know who to do that in front of and
not and you figure that out very quickly
sometimes adding a little levity yeah
some humor to the situation
because you're dealing with the most
horrific traumatic things you can
imagine
you know when somebody's like I I get
crap sometimes on these interviews where
I'm
almost laughing at the absurdity of some
story that somebody's telling not
laughing at that when I hear you laugh
at the same time I'm laughing when I
watch your videos yeah because it's like
as somebody who's dealing with this
stuff all the time that's how you deal
with it yeah because to not do that you
just break down and cry
well absolutely and and the kids too
they're like you're funny I'm like well
I'm glad I can make you laugh and that's
when they're sitting there telling me
things like you know because I will
always ask a kid did anyone ever tell
you not to tell anyone
because that's really important you can
get a lot of uh perspective from asking
that question
and you hear some horrendous things you
hear like well yeah my dad not just said
not to say anything or he would kill me
and my mom and the dog
okay I understand why you didn't say
anything you know because when I talk to
a kid I've never treated even the
littlest kids like babies I never talked
to my three kids like babies when they
were little and I think that's why I had
kids were very mature in Reading when
they were four and stuff like that
because
I wanted them to have fun and have a
childhood but at the same time I you
know I don't know I just wanted them to
be not walking around like oh I need
this or oh I can't I whining I don't I
don't care for that how much of the
sexual assault do you see comes from
is it 100 from men or is it something oh
absolutely not really nope I mean I'd be
lying if I didn't say most of the
perpetrators are men
but some of the worst
perpetrators and accomplices I know are
female
really yeah because
we all know there's crappy parents out
there
um I was very abundantly blessed to have
amazing parents but there's a lot of
crappy parents who don't protect their
kids
and that's something that's really hard
for me to listen to when I have a kid
tell me
well I told my mom and she didn't
believe me
like two years prior and this has
continued to happen
and there's times when I'm really tired
I get emotional not like blue like not
like that but just people can tell when
you're kind of getting emotional and
I've had kids before like say I've
gotten three hours sleep in three days
those I they tend to hate you harder
when you hear something really sad which
is most of what I hear but these little
kids they're looking into your face and
they're asking to go home with you
because they feel safe already because I
have boundaries I am a structure person
I don't let these kids bounce off the
walls and act a fool when they're there
I'll give them a little bit of leeway
and then I'm like now you're gonna sit
here we're gonna talk about that you can
go honey you don't have to be here
because everyone has a choice the adults
and the kids we don't do anything that
people don't want us to do there not
that people are like oh yeah I get to go
over there and have evidence collected
but at the same time I let everyone know
I'm really proud of you for coming here
you're very brave to come see me and I'm
so happy I'm the nurse that gets to take
care of you and anything that you don't
want to do you don't have to do when
you're here you don't have to have
photos even if mommy and daddy say yes
you're the boss that's scary sometimes
telling a little kid they're the boss
but I want them to know they have
control over that situation because they
absolutely had no control over what
happened to them
um so the the answers that we get from
that like yeah telling Mom she didn't
believe me or mom was a part of the
sexual abuse or mom was making
um their kid do something to a stepdad
or let's do this and video it and it's
put online or I mean we just we hear
everything
and one of those times when I was really
tired and a kid I mean Lord knows
because we hear so many things what they
were saying to me it was a little boy I
just remember that but my eyes just
filled up with tears I was just like I
can't handle this I already had so many
patients and a very short period of time
and this kid just broke my heart and I
remember I looked at him and I'm like oh
no because I could feel it like I could
feel I was starting to like my eyes
filled up and he he was noticed it
immediately and he looked at me and he's
like and here's this kid who was just
sexually assaulted and had been numerous
numerous times and he said are you okay
I almost lost it when he asked me
because I'm like seriously and I said
no actually I'm not really because I'm
sorry that no one protected you
and that's
with the kids that's the hardest because
I can't fathom I was a such a protective
mom and if you ask my kids I far too
protective mom because
um
you're supposed to protect your kids
and that kid was just like right but
you're taking really good care of me and
I'm like right because I care about you
and I know that once when we provide
that initial care to them even though it
had been happening for a long time one
of the other things I say is
when I first meet them I'm kind of
jumping around but when I first need a
family let's just act like they're kids
at that point I'll tell the the kid and
the parents I used to say I will treat
you just like you're my own family
then I realized a lot of families don't
treat their kids good
and
most of them understood what I meant
because they could tell the sincerity in
my voice but at the same time
I had to rethink that because one time I
joked I said and I treat my family good
because they looked kind of and then I
went oh the fact that I even said that
that was weird too like I was like oh my
gosh so what I started saying and what
now what I've been saying for years and
years it's along the same same lines but
I say my name is Sean I'm the forensic
nurse examiner and I am going to treat
your kiddo just exactly how I would want
my own family treated
is it kind of the same and are there
crappy people who might not want their
kid treated well I don't understand that
again I feel like it's safer when I say
that because some people didn't have a
good mom or dad and
um they get what I'm saying
um my main thing is telling them How
brave they are especially the kids and I
also say has did anyone tell you that
this isn't your fault
and they just stare at me and just
recently I had a little boy say
are you gonna be mad at anything I tell
you
and I looked at him and I was like no
and he goes well mommy and daddy were
mad and I said honey because I had
already met his parents very appropriate
good people not that people can't seem
good that aren't but
and I said
I'm a mom and I'm a grandma
and we want to most of us want to
protect the people that we love
and because somebody did something to
you that they shouldn't have
um Mommy and Daddy are upset because
sometimes we feel like we should have
been able to protect you or we're just
upset at the person that did this or
there's a lot of things and I said so
you're seeing a lot of emotions in mom
and dad right now
anger
um maybe saying words you're not used to
hearing they say they want to go kill
this person all kinds of things and but
they're not mad at you
they're mad about what happened but
they're not mad at you and they don't
blame you
and that's when I found out that some
people do blame their kids because I had
a little girl one time that said
um
mommy said it was my fault because of
the nightgown that I was wearing and she
was five
so I'm like well no it was not your
fault it absolutely was not your fault
and I'm sorry that that was said to you
because it was this person's fault
and they did something that was really
bad and I'm so sorry that that happened
to you kids are much more resilient
those are the ones that impact me the
most I'm not saying every sexual assault
that I deal with doesn't impact me but
those those like are a gut punch the
kids
um when they're just sitting here
telling you that stuff especially when
you known it's that it's gone on for
long periods of time I mean your videos
are the prime example your interviews
that I've seen
I don't know if you've heard of the ace
scoring system but if the aces the the
you know adverse childhood experiences
that have happened to some of the people
in your videos
I it's amazing that they're alive
a lot of them because that's the money
around drugs yeah exactly the higher
your a score and I had a couple
um but these people have a ton and when
I ca I literally will calculate their a
score sometimes while I'm sitting there
watching them because it's so hard to
listen your your videos are not easy to
listen to I'm sure you know that
um but I appreciate you having them
there because so many people stick their
head in the sand
and purposely don't make themselves
aware of what's going on and that's
hurtful I mean I my daughter and I see
homeless people all the time when we're
walking down by the river
and just having eye contact with people
makes a huge difference
we wonder why people feel like they have
no worth
and then people can't even look them in
the eye and I used to you know be like
oh they're gonna ask me for money but I
would still always say hi and you know
how are you or whatever and you do and
when I'm on the trail I don't have money
with me I have nothing
um besides well some like self
preservation weapons on us sometimes
yeah no we have yeah we have other
things but um because you know you have
to be safe but the homeless people have
not been the people that I've ever been
that scared of
there's been other people that have made
us I heard my daughter switchblade one
time like in two seconds it was
out and I was like good for you you are
definitely my daughter and
she was right on it because she my
hearing is not that great the older I
get and her and she heard something and
she had it out in two seconds but back
to
giving people dignity and um showing
them their self-worth
is the biggest part of my job and that's
what
that's what I would want to convey I
wish I could change things for people I
can't especially by the time they get to
me at my job I wish I could change
things I wish I had a magic wand it
could take it all away
I can't but what I can do is treat
people well
and
I was brought up in a Christian home
and I made a lot of mistakes growing up
and
um but I always knew I had unconditional
love at home and that's very different
from a lot of the people that you
interview and sometimes I think I almost
feel guilty that I had such an amazing
family and then I'm like no I'm so
blessed that I had that I wish more
people had that because the outcomes
would be so much different I know some
of the stuff that happened to me but
because I had that Firm Foundation
at home
um and probably a lot of people sitting
well not probably a lot of people
sitting on the sidelines praying for me
from the time I was little up till now
up till right now because my parents are
probably nervous about me being here
because I thought when you first called
I thought it was like AI
like artificial like until I was like
this is not this could not be him and I
asked my daughter do you think it's AI
what if it's like a human trafficking
ring obviously I have trust issues from
the job I do yes I mean even like coming
up to this room I knew that was you I
knew it looked like you but I was still
like oh my God
another reason my brother was here uh so
yeah trust issues baggage well you see
the worst of the worst
we do and whenever I think that I've
seen I can't see something worse or hear
something stranger or worse
sure enough I get proven wrong
many times I get proven wrong in that
what's the what's the worst thing you've
seen
um the worst thing I've seen I have to
be obviously careful because of HIPAA by
far
dead children
that died at the hands of your their
abuser now I will say that there's times
that I thought
as horrendous as that was because
there's been some really bad ones
I never had to hear what happened
and sometimes for me I'm an overthinker
I can't even it's a toss-up between
which ones worse obviously a dead child
is horrendous but the kids are able to
tell me everything too is
then I know I have full knowledge of
what happened and I just wonder and like
I just literally will pray for these
kids when they leave like
it's got to be so difficult to let the
kid go he's going back to his family
right yeah sometimes the perpetrator I
mean DCS Department of Child Services
will always be involved if it's anyone
under 18. sometimes separate them
yeah and I and I know that uh
again they have a very high Ace score
um right away in life
and you know unfortunately even Foster
families I've taken care of a lot of
foster kids who were sexually assaulted
in foster homes because of either other
foster kids or foster parents I mean you
know I I am not like my dad I love my
dad to death but he and he's changed a
lot over over time
he just I think he always wanted to
think the best about people and that
people were good and there are a lot of
good people there are you have to find
them but they're out there
but there's so many foster parents
um that
it would be hard to have foster kids
even when you're doing the best best you
know you're awesome people you want the
best for people I don't even know how
you keep an eye on a kid that's been
sexually assaulted because Unfortunately
they can also become the next
perpetrator
which is scary too but we've had to send
kids back into homes where I didn't feel
like they felt safe
because that's not my choice I don't get
to make that choice and I have a lot of
respect for Department of Child Services
because I see what they have to deal
with they're dealing with a lot of the
same things we are and they have to make
scary choices sometimes and you're
trusting that a mom's going to get rid
of that stepdad or their boyfriend
that's been molesting their children
but the system's not always going to
know if they allow those people back in
the house so
I really can't I know which one was the
hardest on me emotionally and it was a
dead kid in the morgue that was
literally
every inch of that kid had injury and
having it in the worst places because
anytime it's anal vaginal anything and I
I'm I because I do overthink and obsess
about things like that sometimes
all I could think about was what was the
last few minutes of that kid's life like
you know and that I just hope that when
maybe they got hit in the head first
that they were out at that point that
they died quickly and I don't know it's
it's it's really weird because like two
of us usually always go to the morgue
and my co-worker it seems like her and I
usually are stuck together going those
same days
and she had a kid about that age that
same age and um it was very difficult on
her very difficult and we're both
talkers and I remember on the way back
after we left that day
and we had really good law enforcement
there that day that kind of warned us
what we were in for
that it wasn't just like a kid that
looks like they're sleeping it was much
worse than that and I don't think we
spoke and like I said we're both talkers
I don't think we spoke one word the
whole way back to work and then when we
get there you're not done at that point
I mean you think oh God you should be
able to like
decompress like do whatever but no you
immediately go because you have to dry
the evidence package the evidence start
your documentation and I think on that
one I had at least five hours just in
charting the injury
because we chart everything by hand
so you're like looking at the photos
again you know for the next five so it
was like
now that being said that day normally I
can go home and I'm weird I'm acting a
little weird I feel like you're just
like in this weird space
but it's usually a couple days after I
do those where it just like hits you
yeah just like that day when I was
driving home yeah and that where I can
and that's why literally and who who in
their right mind sorry would be watching
your videos to relax because I do other
things I mean I listen to music I listen
to podcasts I play Pickleball I swim I
paint rocks and hide them around for
people to find and
um actually I painted you on but I left
it downstairs because I was stressed and
uh just to like I have to do things that
bring me joy and can take me out of that
space
when I get in a funk because of one of
those cases but that same case I had I
think I had five more exams in the next
two days because I was on call that
weekend so I didn't process it till
Monday and Monday was not a good day I
had that day off and I was just like
what in the heck even like what is going
on that one is stuck with me
um as far as visually the most because I
see it I can still I could describe it
to a t right now
but it's the
that's the visual part of it the audio
part of it there's stuff that I've heard
that I can never unhear
never on here stuff that I see that I
cannot see
stuff that I hear that I will never run
here you've been doing this job for how
many years 13. how have those 13 years
changed you
um I was very untrusting prior to this
job so uh
changed me
you're what you're aware now of how evil
the world is sometimes I knew that
before I knew that before
but like doing these interviews I'm
shocked at how many
people have been through sexual abuse
well and I think that that's kind of why
because somehow yours was suggested to
me I don't even know what that meant but
somehow it was suggested to me and I
started watching them and I'm like oh my
gosh this is like these were like my
patients and these are like people who
are self-medicating and you know when we
talked about the aces before the higher
the score you have the more that you
answer yes to it increases your risk for
chronic health problems suicide attempts
mental health issues
um drug abuse yeah
sexual assault is such a horrible thing
but at the same time
I want people to have hope and I don't
want them to feel like that they are um
defined by what has happened to them and
I think again that's part of what I want
to do in my job
I want people to have hope when they
leave and I always after the exams are
over even the youngest kids I'll be like
is that as bad as you thought it would
be because they have people going well
you're going to re-traumatize my kid or
oh my God I watched this on
um SV Law and Order SVU and it's
horrible and I'm like I'm not telling
you this will be easy
but I can assure you that I'm the
perfect person to take care of you today
and I you will feel
empowered when you leave here
I don't know how you're going to feel 24
hours from now I have no control over
that but while you're here you will feel
safe you will feel listened to you will
know that you had good care provided and
you will know that there's something
different about me
and you won't know what that is but
you'll know
okay
would you say your job is fulfilling and
rewarding
it's fulfilling
um it's absolutely fulfilling
it's just hard yeah
and like there's days literally I'm like
why am I doing this
because I can help people and that's
what I want to do and there's the days
I'm the most frustrated because it's
just it can be a very toxic environment
um
because again there's no one coming
there for a happy reason I do a lot of
teaching and educating and those are the
only people walking through our doors
that it's happy because they're coming
to learn about it which is not happy for
them usually but I love educating and
and it's kind of healing as well to do
that
so people know more about it and they're
more aware
what do you think the solution is to the
the amount of sexual abuse we see
as negative as it sounds I
there is none it's always been happening
the good parenting that you you
described it's going to continue right
but I had good parents and it happened
to me yeah nobody more more good
parenting would probably right put a big
dent in it all
yeah it's
um
pornography people don't like to listen
to this or hear this it's not a popular
thing but the accessibility of
pornography now
and the kids the things that little kids
are seeing because I ask my patients
so you're only seven and some of these
things were happening with you and
another child
did you see this from someone is it
something you saw on TV in a movie and a
picture in a video did you walk in on
your parents like where did this did
something happen to you previously
because we kind of want to establish we
want to make sure that that kid is also
we know that some of the child
perpetrators are being perped on as we
speak so we're always trying to back it
up to be like okay this kid did
something horrible what happened to that
kid and then you're kind of like moving
back to try to find out how many kids
are being affected in this group and
trying to get everybody in for forensic
interviews
and
um the accessibility of pornography and
people having their little phones all
the time and these kids that have my
kids if they were little would never
have any of these smartphones or there
would be so much blockage on it it
wouldn't even there would be no point
they might as well have a flip phone
and there are kids who
know how to get online and find all of
that and I know there are just some
legislation that came through recently
in a couple States about trying to
minimize the accessibility and age
restrictions and certain entities that
they make a lot of money off of that
being really upset about that
I feel like everyone should think that's
the messed up thing is trying to well
there's always going to be ways to get
around things we do know that but why
not have it in place can we minimize I
think
yeah why do we want kids to see these
kind of things it's bad enough that
stuff is happening to them but they're
seeing it and they want to act some of
the things out so it's not just kids
that have been perped on it's kids that
have seen these things and they end up
perpetrating and it's just I wish I
could say that there's a solution to
getting rid of sexual assault but it'll
never happen but the outcomes can be
um
can be changed to where they're
they at least have a better chance of a
positive outcome
a lot of your videos that I've watched
in the interviews
um I don't talk about faith I'm not
going to go on and on about it now
because that's not the way I roll I care
um but I think people seeing you're
different sometimes you can plan a seed
without saying things
but
most of the people in your videos that
have
had a better outcome even after some
real crap like Johnny the the gang
member that now is like working in jail
Ministry and stuff like that
I think I'm safe to say you can agree or
disagree that most of the people that
have had a positive outcome have said
something about God or Jesus
and I believe that because our worth is
never going to be
sorry
self-worth is the huge thing with the
population that you video most of the
time an interview
your worth is never going to be
determined by where you lay your head at
night
how much money you have the atrocities
that have happened to you
um how many friends you have what kind
of shoes you're wearing
I believe beyond a shadow of doubt that
all of us are worthy in God's eyes
and that every one of us is his
masterpiece
and if everyone knew that and I know
people say how could these horrible
things happen to people if there's a God
well there's a lot of horrible people
and
I don't regret anything that happened to
me in my past
some choices I've made I absolutely have
some regrets about that
but as far as the things that happened
to me when I was younger that my parents
had absolutely no control over
nor did I
um
I don't regret it I absolutely don't
because while that is not the reason
that I went into forensic nursing has
nothing to do with it it did not enter
into it one bit
um
mine was more because I'm methodical and
detail-oriented and all those kind of
things I thought it would be fit for
that job and I knew I cared about people
because that's what was modeled by my
parents they cared
they were consistent they were punctual
which you obviously know I am since I
got here two hours early
um
but they lived out their faith every day
I'm the least religious person you'll
ever meet but I agree with you 100
it's nice to know I was really proud of
Johnny in that video
and I hadn't watched his and when you
when I watched some of your interviews I
was like if I say anything he might just
edit it out and
um so I was overthinking because that's
what I do best everything that I was
gonna say
and when I saw that one I felt better
because I knew you not only allowed it
you had him come back a second time
because
I saw how many people watched his and
how many positive comments were on his
and you we all know there's a lot of
haters because my daughter's like if
this thing gets out there don't look at
the comments because you overthink
everything and you'll be like what she's
right
um
because a lot of people don't want to
hear those things like some people might
think it's terrible I said dead baby I
know that sounds very slang and bad
because it's a deceased child
um
but that's literally what I thought that
day I cannot take care of dead babies I
can't do this so I'm not saying it
disrespectfully I know it doesn't sound
politically correct and I know I
probably worry about that too much
because nowadays everybody gets like
oh gosh everything comes at you now if
you say the one wrong thing
um and I shouldn't care what I do
anyway
I work with a lot of law enforcement
Child Protective Services
uh therapists
not really work right beside them always
but we have somewhat kind of the same
um
job at the end of the day
and there's a lot of us that are in
healing Fields fields that we went into
because we wanted to be a part of
healing people and serving people and
helping it's more actually helping than
healing
and a lot of those people that I've come
and contact with over the years were
people who suffered at the hands of
abusers as well
and
I just have to think that
that's that's also something we do for
us which sounds selfish again that's
never why I went into the field I'm in
but it helps us too
anybody that knows when you feel the
crappiest and the most down
that's why I paint rocks and it sounds
so stupid I get them when I'm up in
Alaska these perfect little smooth rocks
and I paint things on them and I hide
them and then people post them online
because there's groups all over the
world that do this and it's such a
stupid little simple thing and there's
people that will post I found this rock
on the day my mom died and it's like
that just sounds so dumb but it means
something to people and if I can do that
and if all the other people that I know
who are in these fields can do that and
just anyone like I said eye contact with
a homeless person walking down the
street
I heard a saying and I'm probably going
to butcher it but it was something along
the lines of
the final stage of healing is when you
use what happened to you to help other
people and any day that we can do that
it's a good day it's a really good day
what a wonderful talk
thank you Sean thank you for inviting me